I've been thinking a lot about this
first sort of month in a few days of the
new administration and we recently did a
segment about how Donald Trump has made
very little impact on policy so far most
of his executive orders are sort of
symbolic statement of preference by the
White House the real tangible action
that he took the Muslim majority country
immigration ban was struck down in court
and some federal government direction
here and there directing agencies to act
more in this way or that way and that
does matter but the Obamacare repeal is
really really really far from happening
a replacement is even further away and
I'm coming to realize and so is Ramesh
Ponnuru who wrote an interesting article
about this in Bloomberg that Donald
Trump is showing himself to be basically
a weak president and by the way Ramesh
Ponnuru is an editor for the
Conservative National Review magazine a
visiting fellow at the conservative
American Enterprise Institute our
previous presidents accomplished way
more during their first month in office
and you can't argue that this is because
Trump has to fight the House and Senate
because Republicans have the White House
the Senate and the House of
Representatives there's really no reason
that Trump would have accomplished
almost nothing other than the symbolic
nonsense that have been talking about
and his attempts at authoritarian
decrees other than the reality that he's
just weak and fumbling around and
completely disorganized in terms of his
administration put aside the orders and
the decrees there has been no major
legislation period from Donald Trump
he's been in office for over a month now
at this point in george w bush's
presidency when he had been president
for about a month he already had
outlined a major tax plan that he was
about to sign into law we're still
waiting to see if and what Donald
Trump's tax plan is going to be he
flaunted that the entire campaign
supposedly a major issue that he would
act on quickly a month into President
Obama's presidency he had already signed
three laws that were monumental to his
presidency you had the stimulus package
the program to expand
health care and the lilly Ledbetter Fair
Pay Act now you might hate those things
you might say those were bad ideas but
they are real things that were done
Trump is nowhere near having made any
impact and after his first day in office
think progress had already counted on 34
campaign promises that he had backed off
of he has still signed no major
legislation we've heard nothing about
any plan to reform taxes health care or
infrastructure in ways that are actually
actionable Trump is just week isn't he I
think he just doesn't really understand
how government works I mean a lot of
politics is getting into the
nitty-gritty and maybe he just thinks
that Republicans in Congress will take
care of these things for him
but if you want to get what you want
passed I mean you have to be involved in
the process and use the bully pulpit
he's just turning around to Mitch
McConnell and Paul Ryan and saying why
can't you just do it for me well that
may be true with legislation but it goes
even further because Donald Trump is
also indicated to be really just a
weakling he's way behind past presidents
and even filling appointments and hiring
people for his administration you'd
think he would have worked that stuff
out before the election or during the
transition period again you've got
Republicans running the show there's no
reason why there should be so many
positions still open more than a month
into his presidency more than three
months beyond election day yes Senate
Democrats have pushed back against some
nominations but this is an issue of
organization of administration and of
will to move forward and Trump is
scrambling and struggling to do just the
basic things that new presidents need to
do meanwhile he's taking weekly
vacations at the cost of about 12 times
more than what President Obama was
spending on travel he doesn't seem to be
taking control of his White House which
is in disarray we've talked about it
being basically unclear who's actually
calling the shots there he's got these
overbearing and overwhelmingly in
control advisers also achieving nothing
and in general Trump's not a leader he's
really just not taking a leadership role
and we'll talk about polling on this a
little bit
later you need to do something at some
point and Trump has the reputation for
being this domineering authoritarian and
in rhetoric he absolutely is he's of the
most authoritarian rhetoric of any
recent president but in a lot of ways
he's proving himself to be impotent when
it comes to action well with regards to
his cabinet picks I think some of them
were just so far out there that even
Republicans couldn't get behind them two
Republicans voted against Betsy DeVos
for education secretary yeah and then
Andrew puzzler wasn't even going to
stand a chance because a lot of
skeletons in his past so maybe he'll
take a lesson from this and become more
moderate oh sure yeah trump's going to
learn something that requires humility
you know where Trump actually crushes
Obama in terms of productivity scandals
Trump had more scandals between election
day and inauguration day than Obama had
in eight years Trump has had more
scandals and embarrassment in the first
34 days in office than Obama had in
eight years quite the overachiever there
how can any trumpet honestly look at the
situation and say Trump is anything but
just a weakling impotent figurehead
sitting there in the Oval Office